Alicia is with us in Houston Texas hi
Alicia how are you I'm not thank you
good how can I help so my question is
I'm looking for your advice I just found
out my husband told me it seems that his
family is starting to give him a hard
time about our choices following your
principles and just in general money and
planning and trying to be intentional
about it and it's very very different
from the way that he was brought up and
they really don't understand and are
criticizing him and so I'm looking for
advice to possibly some things he could
say next time it comes up and some
advice for me to support him as well but
how old are you - I'm going to be
turning 29 he's actually 34 okay and how
long have you been married about three
years okay well you've reached the point
that you are realizing that um that you
did make decisions as adults in your
household and it's none of anyone else's
business right it's called being a
grown-up and his mommy doesn't get to
tell you what to do anymore right you
know you ever heard the old-fashioned
wedding vows when they say you leave
your parents and cleave old-fashioned
old old English word from the old
English Bible cleave to your Hut to your
spouse that's what your husband needs to
do and so what he has to do is he is to
just you know let's pretend this was
just a friend of yours who said I don't
like the type of car you bought I think
it's I think it's a joke to which you
would say I really didn't ask your
opinion I wasn't taking a survey when I
bought it it's my car I like my car I
made fun of my friend he bought one of
those little leaf cars the other day and
I was giving him a hard time I was in my
Raptor and I told him I said if you need
a ride I can just put you in the back I
mean I was really giving he goes Ramsey
I don't really give a crap what you
think about my little leaf I like my
little leaf you shut up about my leaf
and we're buddies so he can say that you
don't be that mean to his mama right but
you know what I'm saying it's none of
their dadgum business
and that's a car to be in a man it's
none of their business their job is no
longer to tell you how guys how to live
and so this family has boundary issues
yes thank me and by the way they're not
winning with money are they no so we
really don't want to mimic anything
they're doing with money yep so that's
you know what you do what you tell him
is honey we are going to make the best
choices that are good for us we are now
grown-ups we're over freakin 30 yeah and
we're going to just smile and be kind to
these crazy people that are your family
and we're going to just say I'm not
going to deal with it I'm not you know
you're not going to talk them into
anything and they're not going to talk
you into anything if you've got a
backbone right but the problem is not
them the problem is is he's responding
to their pressure he's starting to think
he's crazy because they said he's crazy
so it he's the problem I'm not saying
he's a bad guy
but I'm telling I'm speaking to him
right now you serve time to get you a
backbone square your shoulders your mama
doesn't run this house and that's the
deal because I mean any time your family
speaks to you like that
you start to if you're human it's
happened to me I've been in his shoes
when people questioned my choices that
that I care about and they are supposed
to care about me and it makes you think
you're crazy
and you're not crazy you just have a
brain you are doing good financial
things and they never have and so they
can't stand it that you might do
something different yep so I have a
prediction for you if you're kind and
firm and just say look this subjects off
limits because if you keep talking about
you're going to make me mad okay and I
don't want to talk about this and be mad
and I don't want to be mean to you we're
going to do this mom and dad so you guys
can just stand over there and think
we've joined a cult or you can stand
over there and think we're crazy or
whatever but we're going to do it now if
you're kind and you don't create a major
relationship rift over this which you
should be able to do okay when you go
win and you're starting to make money
they'll start calling
you on the slide one of the time and
asking you how you did it they'll come
around but you guys got to decide you
know I mean just the way I like to think
of it is is I think think of a this is a
whole house full of fat people telling
you your diets not going to work right
right but so I feel also even already
and be coming from them much fun cuz we
are winning that's flat hard that's fine
that's part of winning okay you know one
of the problems with making money is the
people say stupid stuff yeah people say
stupid stuff to me all the time they say
like you're so lucky what didn't have
crap to do with this it is not luck I've
worked my tail off for 25 years now I'm
an overnight success
it was my hard work my smarts and God's
blessings and not in that order God's
blessings my hard work and my smarts
they got us where we are
luck didn't anything to do with it and
there's people that don't understand
that okay bleep you look at you look at
you well that's fine look at me shut up
you know it's like I keep me from going
and being the best I can be I'm not
rubbing me buddy nose in it they're the
ones decided to have an attitude right
there's only one way to avoid criticism
Aristotle said say nothing do nothing
and be nothing and so you're always
going to put up with mediocre people
with an attitude when you go in whether
they're in your family or not it hurts
more I guess when they're in your family
it hurts the closer they are to you
they're supposed to be your cheerleaders
and sometimes they're not yeah but
there's crazy and every family you know
that yeah if you think Craig there's not
crazy in your family it's you you know
there's crazy and every family it's just
part of it and you just smile no that's
all right I get it I mean I got people
my family they're Democrats go figure I
mean yeah there's that there's one
member my family's an Alabama fan I
can't believe it you know something
they're everywhere you know so it's just
you just have to enjoy the differences
and have reasonable boundaries the
problem is they're crossing emotional
boundaries by picking
you guys for doing something that means
a lot to you when they ought to be
cheering you on
yep that's that's hitting the nail on
the head and that should hit Hertz and
so this is this is a grown-up moment
where you guys are set up an emotional
boundary around yourself and go they no
longer have permission to hurt my
feelings on this subject because they're
not winning on this subject they're
losing on this subject so their opinion
is invalid their pitiful rest of the
time we can just be coming too late
Mama's macaroni she's good at that but
she's not good at you know investing and
it's been horrible handling money hey
you guys Rachael Cruz here hope you are
enjoying the Dave Ramsey show and did
you know that I have my very own YouTube
channel yes that's right kind of better
than the Dave Ramsey channel don't tell
them I said that I'm kidding I'm kidding
so subscribe and there's lots of videos
about life and money so while you're at
it if you want to check out a video then
you can check out how to do a monthly
budget
it's one of the best videos out there
you